every night
i dream the same dream
then
so first of all strange is he likes to
fix things he's a perfectionist yeah
he might have made some mistakes along
the way or was there no other way does
he going into this film have regrets do
you think about some of the decisions
he's made where do you want me to start
with all of that
i would say
no regrets no i think he's a character
who's learning despite his arrogance and
his willfulness and ego i think he does
he he can bend he can adapt and that's
one of the joys of playing him you get
to have some pathos and some
you know moments where he's properly
schooled and taught that what he's done
isn't necessarily the right or best
thing to have done
and this is another step in that
evolution you know i think in spider-man
no way home we saw a man who we've got
to know is
someone who's transferred deferred his
ego and his skills from being a
um
a neurosurgeon to being a sorcerer who
while not being a supreme sorcerer in
this version is who's omnipotent and
omniscient and just only everything
um
and that's kind of held in check a
little bit in that film he all the
mistakes he makes so are very human and
relatable i feel like he is someone who
cares for a fellow foot soldier in the
first instance with pizza then sees him
as a kid who's lost his guardian and his
way in his own life
and wants to give him something
that can help him get back and does it
in a very cavalier showing off way and
then it gets interrupted and everything
that happens in that film happens
and then he becomes a sort of bad parent
you know chasing him around the city
asking for the toy back and
yeah [ __ ] it really hits the
so
but it's human that's a great phenomenon
he cares [ __ ] hits the fan yeah
that should be the tagline um yeah
basically he he cares he does he cares
for for people outside of his own
existence and um
[Music]
we all make mistakes from that when that
happens
sam's talked about and it's been
confirmed i'm not trying to get spoilers
but that you play at least a version at
least one version of strange in this
film whether it's a dream whatever it is
for you as an actor do you approach that
character as a totally new character or
do you springboard off what you've
existed what's existed look i think if
it's if it's still me playing strange
however different the circumstances um
it's important to understand that
there's some kind of origin point that's
the same
um so that's why it's me is the same
actor that's why um i think it feeds
into our understanding of our strange
you see these other characters in
whatever moments you see them having
made choices that result in different
outcomes and
i think that's what the multiverse is a
storyline is great at reflecting of our
own lives the sort of multiple selves we
contain the different roles we are
always playing
in our lives and how our choices affect
the outcomes of our lives was there one
particular aspect of
either
going deeper into the strange character
we know or something that you got to
play that was fresh that was
particularly exciting that you can talk
about all of it i would say because you
know
it's great to have my own outing
although it's a very crowded marquee
there's a lot of story and a lot of
characters in this it's not all about
strangers your name is on the title yeah
yeah um but i think it's it's
what am i saying yeah no you learn a lot
about him through what he goes through
but also seeing these other versions of
him and i think
that evolution is important it keeps it
keeps people engaged with him and that's
what's rich about him as a character
yeah he's snarky and arrogant and we
kind of vicariously enjoy that sometimes
but you know he's also not down to size
and he's also taught he also is evolving
this is a kind of a two-parter but how
long would you want to play you've sort
of talked about how this is the tip of
the iceberg it's only scratching the
surface because the multiverse is
blowing up just stepping up how long
would you want to play this character
for in other iterations i don't really
want to put a time on it but i'm having
i don't feel like i'm in the middle or
the beginning i just don't know i i'm
having a really good time i'm having a
really good time being your doctor
strange and i enjoy it and
i left this film going oh yeah i can't
wait for fans to see where he's got to
here but i'm i'm even more excited as to
where he goes next so
you know i'm i'm still um i'm still
going for it if you guys are would a
series be interesting do you think it
would be
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
mean you know it's nice to have the kind
of work i do outside of this and i think
a series obviously as a time commitment
is almost as big as a movie um and when
it's your series you'll as lizzy will
tell you on all the time
so i don't know i don't know uh sam
yeah i know you were a fan of the
original spider-man films what aspect of
those films did you love and what sort
of nuggets that are very spiderman-esque
did you sitting across from him i know
you've done a funny impression of him as
a director sort of like what sort of
freshness does he bring to this to this
story
i mean
fans of his evolved will love this
there's a lot of nostalgic sam raimi
touches in his delivery of moments of
horror the kind of schlock horror
element of it
the the the fun he has with
gore in inverted commas who knows what
that means in the multiverse uh you'll
find out um and also jump scares and all
the other traits of horror movie making
and also the darker tone as well and he
handled that as well as the complexity
of the characters and the situations
with real clarity and uh at ease
but the thing i learned most about him
was he's just so amenable he's such a
great collaborator brilliant first
audience he always wants you to try
things and skew the script and come up
with new ideas and
um
and he's so humble i mean to a fool
sometimes he had to kind of remind
himself that he was directing a big film
i thought you were going to do an
impression oh god well you said you set
me up for a fool but you know he's like
you know i i'm gonna
stop in this thing strange it's here and
then this bus comes from me and you cut
it like a butter like
and then it falls into two halves i feel
so cruel during your personalization
it's not fair in another multiverse
story you're playing him i play him all
right yeah and he plays he plays strange
i'd love to see his strength
i have
i mean you know that's the thing he's so
animated and he will give you a whole
breakdown of the scene and he just can't
help but sort of do it and play it out
all the parts he runs from one place
back to the other you know
um
but he's he's a dear man i'm very very
fond of him and and i think he's handled
everything that's been thrown at him
coming into this franchise late this
particular moment of it and in the mcu
um so brilliantly and
uh it's it's very much a sam raimi film
i love it thank you thank you so much
for your time thank you you're welcome
it's fun
one day
somewhere later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
first of all uh
one division ruined me emotionally the
last episode
um i'm not over it yet um we've seen the
first 20 minutes of this film i'm
wondering if you could kind of describe
your dynamic sort of onset with benedict
cumberbatch versus some of the other
characters in the mcu um he's actually
very funny like in my interview with him
he was doing sam raymond impersonations
so what do you bring out from each other
as collaborators that's maybe different
and also the strange and wanted dynamic
because they're two possibly the most
powerful
um superheroes in this universe
um well
i i think
the way we we really cared about trying
to figure out how to carve these stories
or this film and continue why people
love these characters and also advance
them in some way and that was but that
was very important to both of us so we
actually had like a very heady
analytical experience together as well
um but he does have um
such a kindness and a goofiness to him
that i think i'm seeing more of doing
press actually than then while shooting
which has been a joy for me to to get to
travel with him and see that part of his
personality a bit more because it was
definitely felt like we were filming
during lockdowns there was like such a
grind to making this film to trying to
get it right um even though there were
you know moments of levity and more than
anything i just really find him to be um
a very accomplished and
um incredible actor to get to be a part
of his process like that and to share
the screen with him was was a joy for me
so how would you describe that strange
wanda dynamic i know it probably takes
on different iterations in this film but
whatever you can tell me
um well i think of them as people who
actually understand one another um very
well
and
they just happen to be kind of in
different places of their own personal
growth and maybe have um slightly
different perspectives
got it i like it actually that's a
wonderful answer it's interesting very
intriguing um and again as much as you
can sort of tell me i know kevin and sam
have disc have have said and it's okay
to say it that both you and doctor
strange are playing different iterations
of your character in this film can you
tell me which one was sort of the most
interesting or fun for you to explore as
an actress
i think the thing that i had the most
fun with was playing this universe's
scarlet witch and and kind of um
the the evolution that we have created
for her it was
really fun actually i think i i
preferred it by far because
there is um there's a lot more to play
and
um a woman who i've spent so much time
with in this
in this universe
so it was um it was fun to continue and
and advance her on her journey
um speaking of your journey i know i
asked benedict the question he says he's
really enjoying being in this universe
and wants to continue it tom holland has
said he will play spider-man for the
next 20 years how long do you think you
want to play wanda for and are you
interested in sort of carving out maybe
her own
film or would you like to do a season
two of one division what is sort of the
more better way for you to flush out the
character
um i
i really thought of this film as a story
that um was told between
there it ends the way it's supposed to
end
and i
i'm always i'm very curious what the
fans want next as well because i don't
have any ideas um and so i think that
would be helpful to get some ideas from
them um
i my whole thing without having like
these big picture deals or whatever to
you know go nine times or whatever it is
um is that as long as and this is what
happened with juan division as long as
there's a good story to tell i'll be
there um but i don't think it's it's fun
for the fans for us to just like show up
and not have anything interesting
to share or to tell or to explore and so
for me it's always about the story if
there's a good idea i'm happy to play
her i also think
her being old will will actually be kind
of amazing and the comics she
her power um kind of uh deteriorates her
and ages her in a way um in some in some
of the comics and i do think of that as
being kind of amazing and i i kind of
imagined myself one day with like
prosthetics and
silver hair and like playing her as this
like like older wise woman and so i do
have this kind of this dream of aging
her quite a bit so maybe i'll play her
when i am sure i love that maybe i just
really think she's ancient in in her
like the myth of the scarlet witch is
this ancient myth and so
that's something that i kind of adore
about about you know a potential future
that i'm just kind of throwing out and i
don't really know where it would go i
know you're not on social media so i'm
wondering how you get the fan reaction
if people tell you that you're pretty
much trending every day because the fans
love you so much if you get that
feedback and if
if not to be cheesy if you have a
message for your fans via us that you'd
like to give them
yeah i really
i really want them
to enjoy this film be open to the ride
and i really want
their ideas i feel like when we were
filming when one division came out and
these weekly
um guesses were happening that i would
hear from doing interviews mostly so if
you hear them um
i
i thought oh god i wish we knew about
the multiverse then but like we didn't
and so there are things like that that i
just feel like the fans are so on top of
these characters and the mcu as a whole
that i just really want them to throw
out what they want next like desperately
because i do think there's there are
nuggets that the fans create that
is something that i i don't necessarily
think of
[Music]
you okay
so
legend has it 20 years ago when you were
pitching yourself to direct the first
spider-man movie you basically said it's
a soap opera about a boy and a girl you
didn't focus in on the action
how would you describe this movie in one
sentence
this
is dr strange having a chance to look
himself in the mirror
a cracked mirror
a funhouse mirror yeah he called it
something else he called it he called it
a sh
expletive show
um it's got a lot in this movie there's
a lot there was a lot for you to tackle
in this movie um it's been a long time
since you've directed a superhero film
the first three kevin feige was an
assistant on those films
now he's the head honcho did he kind of
give you the keys to the kingdom in
terms of creating these new multiverse
these universes we never seen before was
it a clean slate for you and how has the
superhero genre changed since the last
time
um you you directed a film well kevin
doesn't give anybody the keys to the
kingdom he's very particular about
making sure that the integrity of the
characters stay intact if you do that
though he supports you a thousand
different ways from sunday and um it's a
pleasure working with them because it's
very rare to have a company
who really is
trying more than anything to please the
fans
yeah not not the shareholders so how is
that how are things changed for you like
what sort of technology or sort of
elements were really uh fun for you that
you didn't get to explore in past films
because it didn't exist
well a lot of things were much easier uh
the technology of creating the cgi
creations the process of working with
the teams and the way we could send
media back and forth
but primarily the job is the same it
wasn't tremendously easier or different
and the job is
create or identify within the character
the human qualities
that the audience can connect with
present them on screen and make the
drama have something to do with that so
that the audience can watch
a character maybe that's damaged come
across conflict and and grow and heal or
someone who is
like in the case of spider-man uh
wrestling with the understanding of
responsibility becoming a responsible
young man so it's about
the the core job of directing
hasn't changed it's really about
connecting with the audience i know that
you loved spider-man for the fact that
you felt you could identify with the
character maybe growing up how do you
identify with strange what sort of
kinship do you feel with that character
well now that i'm a little older i can
identify with his problems he's got a
very big ego this guy and he thinks that
only he can do it right
and he doesn't want to share the job or
trust anyone but himself he's probably a
very insecure person inside and has
built up this ego as a shell to cover
that insecurity
but as a director i struggle with my ego
too you know i count on my ego to tell
the story i directors read a book or a
screenplay and their job is to tell the
crew and the actors exactly how they see
it
i mean talk about an egotistical job
it's like who cares how you see it what
about how i see it but that is the job
of the director to explain to the set
decorator precisely who the character is
so that they can use their artistic
talent to put up
the right poster on the wall for the kid
and the right knick-knack near the bed
that would be important to that
character that you describe
so the director's vision
really guides god's everything did you
go to multiverse camp for this how much
studying did you have to do and are
there any rules in the multiverse i
didn't know a thing about the multiverse
i did have to go to camp a little bit
marvel explained where we had been in
the multiverse they referenced comic
books in the past many of which i had
read as a young man
um and they pointed out story lines from
the pre-existing avengers movies or one
division and i had to be aware of all
these things along with writer michael
waldron in bringing all these story
lines
and the
concept of the multiverse forward
you have a lot of different sort of duos
and dynamics in this film there's sort
of a new duo and sort of dynamic between
strange and wanda that we haven't fully
explored before you also have america
she's a little bit defiant from what
i've heard against strange she's not
super impressed um how important is it
and how on a storytelling level do you
make sure you get those relationships
right and make sure they're all
different within the film
that's really the most important job
that you describe
the audience has had these experiences
with these characters and they know them
they know them they've seen them
they've talked about them they've
written about them
and they've waited for the next
installment
so my job more than creating something
from whole cloth was in understanding
who they were
learning from the actors
taking in marvels and the avengers story
lines moving forward right and telling
the next installment
that is a logical progression from where
all the fans have been i know we all had
an emotional reaction to watching toby
walk through the portal and spider-man
no way home what was your personal
reaction what emotion did you feel maybe
as a dad figure
and what aspect of where he's at right
now i know you talked to my colleague
and said you'd be interested in
exploring a spider-man film what aspect
of where he's at now would be
interesting for you to explore in a
future film
well my reaction to seeing no way home
was it was very emotional it was really
great storytelling and
i thought oh my gosh you just told me
again this william info it was very uh
fun not just because i really like the
characters but we spent
many years together crafting those
movies so it was kind of like a reunion
and moving forward was there an element
of sort of i love the fact that he's a
little bit older he's a little bit sort
of like you feel the pain of what he's
been through what part of that would you
love to explore of that aspect of where
he's at now i haven't thought about it
at all i don't actually have a plan to
make a spider-man 4 right now um i think
colombia is doing really well with their
spider-man movies they probably don't
want to go back and make a spider-man
for but
as a director that worked on a
screenplay for some time
it's always hard to get that out of your
head the uh
the baby that you never had
so how bonkers is this movie gonna get
it gets kind of crazy it's like
a journey not into one universe or two
but on and on you go
and the multiverse is
a frightening place only because it's so
similar
many of the universes are very similar
to ours and just the slightest variation
can show you the wrong path that you may
take in life or the path that you should
have taken when you meet these altered
versions of yourself easter eggs that
fans can look out for maybe a scene i
don't know if you want to point out to
any specific easter eggs or a specific
scene that people should look out for
when they watch this film to find one
yeah i think there's a nice scene of
america chavez bringing
doctor strange through the multiverse
that's a lot of fun and that's something
the audience could look forward to i
think
[Applause]
ah
so first of all congratulations i heard
kevin feige has renamed the mcu the wcu
the wong cinematic system yeah thank you
there's nothing we can do about it yeah
you've been in every marvel movie now
yeah pretty much yeah pretty much
feels good it feels pretty good yeah and
congratulations to you yes um this
they've shown us 20 minutes of this film
it kicks off with gargantos a mega scene
what was the most bonkers thing you got
to do obviously there's no animatronic
thing that big well of course our bit
you know i was i was pretty crazy we did
like this ratchet kind of like uh
pullback
swire
thing i don't even know what it's called
but it was really cool because i i
actually this is my first time doing
like wire work wow so um
it's kind of scary
but we got to do a little bit it was
cool it was great and then you're like
oh my lasso
swinging you down
so cool i mean long moments oh thank you
i mean but like you know full credit to
sochi i mean we gotta remember i mean
she was 14 at the time yeah you know um
you know helming this movie and uh yeah
she's done a fantastic job that's
amazing it's amazing it makes me feel
like i haven't done enough with my life
let's talk a little bit about that i
know that elizabeth gave you some advice
maybe about owning it because you kind
of taunt steven a little bit you're not
too impressed with the new generation
she talked to you about owning it you
also got maybe a dm from
liu so can you talk about sort of how
the members of the mcu sort of empowered
you to sort of owning it and that
relationship was strange and sort of
like holding your own against him well
it's pretty crazy because i mean i grew
up with the mcu you know so it's
definitely been like
i used to have action figures of all
these people in the poster i mean
it's just pretty crazy that now i'm like
you know did you have this um
your first action figure we both have
our first action video that's been crazy
amazing and for you what kind of
sorcerer supreme do you think you've
been so far to stephen compared to the
previous like how what do you think
you've taught stephen so far
well it's been a great character
progression you know from this
no-nonsense librarian to you know this
no-nonsense uh sorcerer supreme and he
you know he's there to sort of quell
this egoic dr strange this wayward
doctor strange
and uh you know they're they're they're
very choking cheese you know they both
need each other though definitely
where do you both see like if you kind
of have your dream i don't know how much
conversation you had with kevin or the
team at marvel sort of the arc of where
america could go in this franchise and
like would you be interested in a tv
series or or standalone films how would
you feel about it all of the above yeah
i'm like open anything um look i mean
it's uh again i mean i i i think back to
six years ago and the foundations that i
uh were built for my character you know
this is only the beginning for you and
uh
as we know it's always a need to know
basis so we're just uh looking forward
to see what unfolds okay about another
universe what would be the dream match
up for either of you which character
would you love to meet up with
i mean i would love to still have walls
come on
i'm someone else send someone else
okay if he wasn't here um
i don't think i could handle that um
i'll be empty
no um but maybe
loki i think that could be a fun
pairing i think that would be fun to
watch
okay let's hang out with the fantastic
four or
the x-men
yeah
i like that one can go wherever he wants
with his portfolio
yeah so you can yes so what was sort of
like
there's been so many incredible moments
in the mcu and as audience members
sometimes you guys don't get to see the
film ahead of time what has been the
moment throughout the mcu that have hit
has hit you the hardest because i think
maybe for a fan you experience it
differently than you because you sort of
know what's going to happen yeah but
what's the moment been for you that's
been sort of like the standout
uh the funeral scene i think you know um
yeah his his passing tony's passing
yeah
well this is hard because i wasn't part
of it
but that's a fan like before but yeah as
a fan i mean especially the funeral
scene
oh but like the last and end game oh
there's so many wand division like just
one division period
i i i
i can't choose
there's too many like there's always
great moments on there in all of these
films in in no way
no i home but i mean definitely like we
you know we have like things that have
happened in one division yeah totally
like things that have happened with one
division
everything's all converging to our
movies this movie to this grand
crescendo i know it's pretty crazy can't
wait to see the film
your desecration of reality
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this
to happen
[Music]
did you create a backstory for yourself
from the events of dr strange
was christine snapped like did you talk
to anybody at marvel about that because
she's at a very different place when we
pick up with her now
right um well it was we there was a lot
of conversation about how different she
would be um you know we wanted it to be
jarring but not so much that she wasn't
that you didn't
long for
them to find
the same relationship or a similar one
that they had before as other people so
um so it was a tricky little dance and
you know
but you want it to be a little bit um
unnerving yeah that you're like do i
know this person or
oh no wait i don't know this person at
all you know that's kind of the fun of
it so for you as an actress did you
envision that you were dusted or did
were you there for the years that people
were sort of in the snap i was not i was
very much alive well i know you talked
in the last film about there was a scene
on set where you were working at
benedict and i think it was a crying
scene and you said you cried all day and
you talked about what a great scene
partner he was there's sort of like when
you meet him at the wedding and this is
not a spoiler but you are getting
married in this one when you meet him at
the wedding there's such a tangible
chemistry between the two of you how did
you create it on this
time around and what was that moment
like for christine how does she feel now
because i feel like this is love in my
life but he's not practical
yes yes i mean weddings are
there's just something so heightened
about them like everyone's kind of on
the verge of tears or laughter or
everyone's not quite themselves
um you're seeing each other in these
epic outfits everybody looks great i
mean there's just something about a
wedding isn't there and alcohol is
flowing and you know i think it it just
lends itself to this specialness and um
last chances and
you know
reflection and regret and so i think i
think it makes her a very charged scene
yeah um and then i think you know we
just
we just have such a history together you
know that's just been built in from the
from from day one with the previous film
so you just kind of have that in there
yeah i don't know what's happening in
this film because we've all obviously
only seen 20 minutes but i know they've
teased like natalie portman she's kind
of like mighty thor she gets like a
really would you want to see something
like that for your character moving
forward in marvel would you love to sort
of get in on the action
i mean i i love
working for marvel uh it's it's so fun
and i love this character so you know
never say never to anything ever in life
i don't know if it happens in this scene
or not but i know she sort of meets in
the comics she meets up with
nightcrawler i think an x-men there's
some x-men crossover
is there anything in there i don't know
how much you've dealt into the comics
that you would like to sort of explore
as a character
um
i can i i think
it's always so fun when when
characters come in and you're like oh i
didn't know they could be here oh great
okay yeah let's do that so um you know
it's always fun to sort of have these
random seemingly random mash-ups that
turn into these great relationships or
great scenes and i just kind of follow
kevin on all of that you know and follow
the mcu and see where you know all these
surprising places it'll take so you know
well i loved what it but i loved all the
possibilities this is my last question
to you the fact that we're delving into
a multiverse
story you personally
if you could meet up with a version of
yourself somewhere what do you think
you'd be doing or what would you like to
see yourself doing or type of
personality would you like to meet up
with
oh gosh wow that's a big question
um i guess i'd like to
speak another language
and be musical
so i'd like to meet um myself as a
spanish concert pianist
it's very fun thinking of eurovision now
or an icelandic uh garageband
player i see a marvel eurovision
crossover in your future
you